hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
recently i'm trying chigorian defense
against queen's gambit
and i found out one very interesting
trap exist in this line so today i'm
going to show you that trap okay queen's
gambit
start with the move white place
d4 and black response with the d5 and
here white base c4
now the normal moves here for the black
are the e6 which is the queen's gambit
decline and c6 which is the slav defense
but the cigarette in defense start with
knight to c6
now you can see i have highlighted by
the arrow over here there are few
options for the white so white can play
knight to f3 e3 or knight to c3 well
against each of them i suggest you go
through the trigger and defense theory
and learn
how to play as a black
but here
we are going to see one of the main line
of the white which is c cross d phi of
course here black will recapture the
pawn and now you can see the first merit
of the black motor is these two pieces
are attacking the d4 square
now again here black has a two reply if
your opponent is going to play this move
which is e3
then
again after e4
white is having a big difficulty and
again i suggest you go to the theory
section but our main trap line exists
when white plays second move which is
knight to f3
now against this
uh the main theory goes with the move e5
but here i recommend a very cunning move
which is this one bishop to g4 and now
you can see two pieces are attacking the
knight
and here
very obvious response of the white will
be first of all knight to c3 so kicking
the queen and here there's one
interesting move by the black which is
queen to e5 and now you can see two pcs
are attacking the knight if it has been
allowed then any moment black can
[ __ ] the white pawn and
that will be a set in the middle game
so very wisely
and i give you a guarantee that up till
now whenever i reach this position
90 percent of my opponent played this
move which is e3 and it's very logical
because now if black capture the knight
white will have a bishop pair and a good
center
so here
we will continue with the castling on
the queen side
and after bishop to e2 which is
unpinning the knight
black will continue with the knight to
f6
and after
castling on the king side by the white
black has a very fantastic move which is
e5
and now you can see if the knight
captured the pawn then black can simply
capture the knight and white cannot
capture the knight because this pawn is
pinned so that's why
here most logical reply by the white
will be and that has been suggested by
the fritz as well
which is to play this move h3
and now you can see the first merit is
it's attacking the bishop
now many attacking maniac will sacrifice
this bishop so for example a simple line
can goes like this so black can play
this move bishop cross h3 but after g
cross h3 queen cross h3 white has this
move which is knight to g5 and
as far as i can see it's not only
attacking the queen it's also attacking
the f7 square and the main drawback is
now this knight will never come to the
g4 square and if white play accurately
black attack will not crash through
and black will be a piece down
so instead of this move
there is a very cunning motor exists for
the black
i give you a few seconds
can you find a very amazing move over
here
okay the move is
e cross d4 and at first side it looks
like it's not possible because
not only white can capture our bishop
but now it's also attacking our queen
but here comes a very good reply by the
black which is knight to g4 now first of
all you can see this pawn is attacking
the knight
and once this pawn moves it will be a
discover attack to the queen
so here there are few replies for the
white and let's have a look each by turn
so for example
let's take the worst one first so if
white
capture this pawn then
black can capture this pawn and as far
as i can see this is almost a lost
position for the white so here if white
will go out of the discovery so for
example white play
queen to e4 then after knight captures
f3 with a chair
any piece capture for example bishop
captures then this leads to the mate
so that is not playable and let's say if
white wants to save the mate bishop to
f4
which stopping the mate but after knight
cross f3 bishop cross f3 and rook takes
d1 rook a cross d1 and bishop to d6
i don't think so it's enough
compensation for the white
and black will have a very easy game
from here onwards
so
e cross d4 is a big blunder by by the
white
now let's
have a look with the other option where
white will
unpin the pawn and give up give the
piece back so for example white can play
this move which is queen to a4
well against this
we can play this move which is first of
all we'll capture the piece
and very logical reply by the white will
be this move which is bishop to b5 and
now you can see two pcs are attacking
the knight
and fortunately black has a very
wonderful move which is bishop to d6 and
now you can see three pcs are attacking
and
if white foolishly grabbed the knight so
for example bishop cross c6 then that
leads to winning position for the black
so a simple line run like this should
bishop check and after king to h1 we
have rook to d6 and now you can see the
idea is very simple
rook wants to swing across to h6 and
then mate the white king at h1 if
white stop that by playing this move
which is e4 then black can simply play
bishop to f4 now it's giving a check to
the white king and after king to
g1
black can play at six and now you can
see
why it is hard pressed to stop the mid
and if
white capture this pawn then we can just
park walking in the corner and no more
chucks there
so very obviously
white cannot capture the knight and that
means that leads to the only reply which
is
rook to e1
so at least
white king can
come out
but
in one of my game my opponent played
like this
and i played knight to e5 so now you can
see attacking the knight
and here i think the most appropriate
move of the wide will be bishop to e2
well even in that case
black will remain
at least one pawn up and attack to boot
but in my game one of my opponent played
this move which is queen cross a7 and he
thought that
he's checkmating me in the next move
but i give you a few seconds
can you find a sequence which will
finish the white
okay the sequence start with the move
knight cross f3 and
please note if
g cross f3 then that leads to the
checkmate into queen h2 check
queen cross f2 mate
so that's not possible so
in the game my opponent played king to
f1
and he thought that he is now in very
good position but he completely
overlooked this move which is queen
check
and now the only move left for the white
is rook to e2 afterwards
can you spot it yep it's
knight to h2 checkmate
now
let's have a look it's the last move
which is
what happens if at this position white
knights will run away so for example
knight to a4 well against this we have a
very good reply start with the move
knight to e5 so now you can see it's
attacking the knight and not only that
we have a sitting target on the h2 so if
the knight moves then uh white king will
be mated at h2
and here the most logical reply by the
wide will be to first of all play rook
to e1 so giving a space to the king and
afterwards we will certainly capture
this pawn so now you can see it's not
only attacking the f2 but it also have a
discovery
to the queen
and here black play bishop cross e3 then
after rook cross queen rook cross rook
bishop to b5
attacking the rogue and after knight to
c3 we'll simply grab the knight and
after white recapture we will simply
grab the bishop and after white
recapture we can play this move which is
knight cross f3 and after bishop cross
f3 between two e5
you can see all the white pawns are
crippled
and
there is not enough compensation here
for the white
and here if the queen runs away for
example queen goes to either c2 or b3
let's say queen to c2
then
black has a
checkmate in three so it's a very good
one so first of all you grab the spawn
so it's attacking the king and rook and
after king to f1 we have queen two h1
check and the only more left is knight
comes in between but afterwards fight
king will be checkmate
so this is one of the very good trap
exist in the chiguran defense and up
till now i have six to seven victims
well best of luck for playing this trap
in one of your own game and feel free to
comment on my video i'll meet you soon
bye